hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday December 26th 2016 what's
going on how are ya oh my god it's the
last Monday a [ __ ] 2016
George Michael passed away on Christmas
Day wake me up before you go-go
condolences to him and you know what the
best thing about 2016 being over is is
you no longer you're gonna have to
listen to people blaming a year for bad
things happening you know that's a big
thing
[ __ ] you 2016 I saw my daughter tweeted
that [ __ ] you 2016 you know why do
people keep blaming the [ __ ] year you
know it has nothing to do with the
[ __ ] year you're talking is people's
genetics are involved there's lifestyle
choices there's substance abuse I mean
that's what's going on here I don't know
why you're you know we're picking on
2016 like it's a religion from the
Middle East or something I have no
[ __ ] idea how it's getting the blame
for all of this you know what I mean
[ __ ] 2016 with your liver cancer
you know let's blame 2016 rather than
the pharmaceutical companies that
[ __ ] was given out opiates like
Flintstone vitamins and created a
[ __ ] heroin epidemic [ __ ] all of that
2016 has robbed us of some of the
greatest artists of our time 2016 like
it's a [ __ ] person how the [ __ ] am I
thought McDonough is world-traveled
she's been around the [ __ ] world
haven't you talked to enough people to
not know to blame a [ __ ] year well
maybe she's saying it metaphorically
bill I don't give a [ __ ] you know if I
try to see her side of the things how
can I come up with a comedic angle to
try to fill out this next [ __ ] 60
minutes
[ __ ] you 2016 oh yeah you didn't like
seeing the Cubs finally win a World
Series huh
nothing good happen to you this year
you're just gonna focus on the bad
anyways I like people awesome then
trying to have like a religious thing
like what a Prince's backup dancers had
this whole [ __ ] religious thing that
she went on saying like you know like
wake up people you know that's that's
when you know you're out of your [ __ ]
like you know when you start telling
people to wake up like like you're
reading the [ __ ] you're reading the
tea leaves better than anybody else and
you're [ __ ] you know garrison
colonial wherever the [ __ ] you live wake
up people
he capital H is is taking us robbing us
of some of our greatest artists you know
like that's a sign like all these these
great musicians are leaving us which
means like what like Jesus is mad at all
the [ __ ] plumbers and electricians
and [ __ ] granted they [ __ ] overcharge
you and they they they lie about when
the date the date of whatever is going
to be done the jobs going to be done
yeah I don't [ __ ] mean I don't
understand I understand blaming a
[ __ ] year you know dude I just can't
wait for this year to be over and then
it's gonna be 2017 I'm not gonna do any
work on myself and I'll basically make
the same [ __ ] decisions I made in
2016 but somehow 2017 is gonna be better
without me having to make any effort
whatsoever Jesus Christ I mean why don't
you just get out your rosary and say all
your [ __ ] prayers rather than [ __ ]
making a positive step towards trying to
make a real change anyway so they talk
about that Madonna thing when she was
shaking her folks she was twerking with
that [ __ ] woman Jesus Christ I mean
unbelievable I just like I hate that she
does that because it makes me feel old
you know when she was she was a hot
piece it's been gonna [ __ ] do anyway
so let's plow ahead this is now this is
not why I wanted to do this thing here
did you guys have a nice holiday
did you have a nice kwang-soo did you
have a nice chat Annika did you have a
nice Christmas
did you hae Jewish people do you guys
like how many you actually uh when I was
a kid people who weren't Jewish told me
how you guys celebrated Hanukkah and I
realized well they weren't really Jewish
were they let me ask you this do you do
how many people do the traditional
things that a one day thing or is it
like a nine day thing how many candles
are on the menorah is it the same as a
baseball team and if so do you give
[ __ ] one gift a day for nine days
like total old-school you know we're
baking our own bread here type of thing
right D is that Oh actually is that a
religious story isn't that there's
always bread
there's always bread there's always fish
there's a [ __ ] leper you know and
then there's always the one guy Abraham
Mohammed or Jesus right hogging up the
whole [ __ ] budget like the same way
they make movies nowadays with Tom
Cruise right he gets all the [ __ ]
money and what about those character
actors that go [ __ ] yourself right you
know back in the day you could you could
make a living as a character actor you
know what I mean not anymore that's not
how it works
not in the age of the [ __ ] superhero
movies so anyways let me see how many
days of Hanukkah I don't know why don't
I look this up Happy Hanukkah Happy
Hanukkah all right how many days in
Minooka there's eight days eight days a
week all right so it's eight days I'm
sorry nine guys on a baseball team eight
days of Hanukkah do you [ __ ] give a
gift every deaths the traditional way as
far as the non-jewish people told me
that they give a gift a day now if you
do that my question my question to you
is how do you give out those gifts you
know how do you do you do it like how I
do is stand up set well you got to start
with something strong
you got to establish that you're the
[ __ ] man for the job right I don't
mean to be sexist about that but when
you really think about it men do a
better [ __ ] job just generally
speaking you know what I mean women have
been nowhere near
[ __ ] moon okay and we were there like
[ __ ] how many years I'm [ __ ] years
ago where we you know oh Jesus I just
felt I just thought of one of the worst
[ __ ] jokes ever and I will not say it
but I will describe it to you okay I
will describe it to you I can't do it I
can only way to get away with it is if
Nia is here also laughing I was gonna
say you put the guys out in space you
know we get all the way to the moon you
know you try to bring a lady up there
right you see where I'm going I can't do
that it's a day after Christmas I would
not do that anyways eight-day so what do
you do do you start off with the [ __ ]
something strong you know and then you
establish like this is the little level
of gift-giving and you gradually start
your ascent through days two three four
five six woo we're going to another
level 7 then 8 you give me LNG a [ __ ]
gift now [ __ ] off for a year that's how
I would do it if I was Jewish all right
man deal with Jewish and I had to get
knee ain't gifts all right well when I
start off with I'd start off with some
shoes all right cuz [ __ ] right I gave
her the [ __ ] some shoes then Jesus
Christ
[ __ ] eight gifts yeah we gotta go
close no you know what I would start
right out of the gate I'd start with
something silly you know like her
stocking stuffer this year like I know
like she knows certain kinds of food she
likes like one year I told her I said I
know I'm gonna get you for Christmas she
could wait yet I'm getting you a bag of
Fritos right she just kept laughing you
know thinking was the funniest thing
ever that I wasn't actually gonna do
it's of course the first gift I gave her
she opened it up it was a bag of Fritos
and I gave her a big bear hug it was
like oh this is the greatest Christmas
ever and she thought it was the funniest
[ __ ] thing ever so if we were Jewish
that's what I would do I would start off
with stupid [ __ ] gifts this who's
kidding who I'm not going [ __ ] broke
here all right is a christian a
non-practicing christian i don't get my
wife eight gifts a year you know what I
mean dude you guys should do it like a
game show okay do you want eight pretty
good gifts a one [ __ ] great one
I think when you win the lottery do you
want to get it all at once or have get
paid a hundred grand over 20 years
and anybody who always takes the
payments doesn't understand money and
also you know it's just like well don't
go to me all once I'm gonna blow it you
get it all at once even though you're in
a bigger tax bracket you know what I
mean
it gets you over the hump into being a
[ __ ] millionaire I'm gonna [ __ ] how
much money you make if they give you 200
grand a year you're never gonna get up
over the million because they're gonna
[ __ ] it they gotta tax the [ __ ] out of
you you take it all at once
roughly I mean you could do it if you
just [ __ ] sat there eating cornflakes
and [ __ ]
but like if you take it all at once and
then you invest it but you're not gonna
know what to do it they wasn't there a
whole documentary on that I have no idea
but why why fortunately like the gifts
that she gave me this year you know it
was funny I made fun to get in socks for
Christmas and she got me sucks and she
was all embarrassed she goes you said it
on Thursday that you didn't like I like
socks I'm just [ __ ] around that was
that was the only thing am i stalking
this year she bought me a little box
three pairs came in this little box a
little I was gonna be cookies and I
opened it up with some Taebaek a Teddy
baked his socks and I don't give a [ __ ]
you know I mean they said I'm an adult
you can't give me a choo-choo train
silver it's [ __ ] over
so anyways okay I'll tell you this quick
story unfortunately Nia
liked her gifts and I always have a
little bit of anxiety whenever I give me
a gifts because the first my first
girlfriend I have a head I think I told
you this story before did I my first
girlfriend I ever had I had to get her
gift now I didn't grow up around the
ladies I just had brothers for the
longest [ __ ] time right and I don't
mean black people I mean I mean I had
like I was related to these people I had
brothers so this coffee's never gonna go
away by the way because the [ __ ]
prescription I got you know just [ __ ]
put it down on the mat and now it's just
[ __ ] hanging
like this thing that won't leave I know
you guys are thinking oh you must be
smoking like a chimney I'm not I'm not
[ __ ] smoking at all / I might be done
with cigars and I'm kind of I'm kind of
done with booze - I just can't [ __ ]
do it anymore you know I love it and all
that [ __ ] but I just hate waking up in
the morning like I'm over you know I'm
over hangovers yeah
I'll have like a beer I'll have like you
know a one glass of scotch at this point
but I can't do the [ __ ] I can't take
the ride anymore
you know what I mean and it just hit me
one day like you know how quickly Brett
Favre got old just BAM done over out of
the [ __ ] league you know he hung
around and he hung around and he hung
around then he took that last [ __ ]
hit when he was on the Vikings you know
and just looked like his clothes were
just laying on the ground didn't even
believe there was a person you know and
all the really religious people got all
concern that you know that they got left
behind and it's like no that's what it
looks like when a [ __ ] 42 year old
guy takes a hit for my [ __ ] defensive
end yeah I'm [ __ ] done with in all of
that [ __ ] however let me tell you the
story the first girlfriend I had so was
her birthday was coming up and I had
absolutely no idea what to get a female
so I go to the mall and I'm looking
around I'm looking around I had no
[ __ ] idea and I came up to this table
and they had all these polo style shirts
nice shirts shirt I would wear and they
were on sale and all that stuff and it
just all these different colors so I
bought her like four of them and I
wrapped him up and I gave him to her you
know eyes ODS and polo shirts and [ __ ]
and she [ __ ] unwrapped these things
and the level of disappointment on her
face and she just was like what what is
what is this what the [ __ ] and dude she
just [ __ ] went off she flipped out
she started yelling at me like like you
know like a head coach man at halftime
you know
you know I said kick the ball away from
you you know flipping out on me and I
literally did I was so embarrassed I
like kind of put my head down I looked
at my feet and then just sat down on the
edge of the bed as she was yelling at me
right and I don't know what happened
embarrassed and she you know I was young
I didn't know anything about women and
[ __ ] and she was just going off on me
and about 3/4 of the way into her rent
which was really a good 90 seconds long
by the way which is [ __ ] forever I
think she was kind of coming to her
senses that she was taking in what she
was doing to me by my body language and
the fact that she just given gotten a
gift and the way she was reacting and
she started to try to pull back on the
stick and be like I know you know it's
gonna and that's when the anger [ __ ]
hit me that was one of the first times
in my ute that I actually addressed my
feelings in the moment you know I was
[ __ ] one of those people brutally like
three days later I'd be like I should
have [ __ ] said something right this
[ __ ] wave of anger came up and I just
you know handle it classically like the
German Irish guy I am
I didn't communicate anything I just
stood up I walked over I started putting
my jacket on and all that now of course
she's [ __ ] no no if you leave doing
all that [ __ ] you know what I mean and
all you want to do is the you know the
you know the swim move that a defensive
lineman does you know you [ __ ] push
to the side and then you [ __ ] bring
your arm up and over that's what I
wanted to do so of course now I'm
walking towards the door and she does
what all what every [ __ ] woman does
in that moment she's blocking the door
and now she's crying she's crying you
know it's like what are you crying about
after everything you just said to me I'm
holding it together pretty [ __ ] good
here so she's crying now she's between
the door I say you know I want to leave
I'm leaving I'm leaving no look you know
and then that then I said awful thing
they standing there
none of the [ __ ] door jamb and you
can't put your hands on them or also you
gonna go to [ __ ] jail even if you're
just trying to remove it's so weird
you don't I mean it's like you're a
human being you want to leave the room
that you're in you're in a free country
there's another human being preventing
you from doing it they're there holding
you there against your [ __ ] will but
they're a [ __ ] so it's totally fine
so what do you do you just have to sit
there not looking them in the eye just
staring at the [ __ ] door like I'm
[ __ ] leaving you can stand here as
long as you want I am going to [ __ ]
leave right
it's brutal you can't you can't you
can't put your hands on and you can't
even try to like you know with the
outside of your arms sort of try to you
know kind of shoehorn your way past them
because then they start flailing around
like deliberately trying to get
themselves hurt during the altercation
so then you feel bad and then you won't
[ __ ] leave they're [ __ ] lunatics
right look at me it still bugs me so you
know I swear to God you know I've always
wanted to come up with something that
you could sell for 1995 late at night
and all these mouth-breathing [ __ ]
morons that think Trump's gonna make the
[ __ ] planet great again or [ __ ]
our United States great again and all
these [ __ ] dumb broads I thought that
because Hillary also had a vagina that
somehow their life was going to improve
those [ __ ] morons right as yet
another day of disappointment has gone
past and they fill themselves up with
buying absolute [ __ ] for 1995 I've
always thought how can I take advantage
of these people for $20 a pop and I'd
you know every time I've come up with
something I find out somebody else has
already invented it like I came up with
this [ __ ] thing that you know you
stick between the car seat and the
console so every time you drop something
doesn't go between the seats someone
already came up with that right that was
the only thing I ever came up with but
somebody already came up with it so it'd
be great if for like 1995 you could come
up with a device that gets the woman
away from the [ __ ] door so you can
[ __ ] leave when they're blocking it
what that does not involve like hurting
them or her at any point also being able
to say that you put your head
so figure it is like I don't know what
you have like you'd have like giant
[ __ ] like these nerf hands okay and
you just put them on either side of her
right and once you stick them on they
just stick on like you know when they
have like those plastic explosives that
you just slap on the side of a tank it's
like once they're on you they're [ __ ]
on you you're gonna owe her a new shirt
all right but at the end of the day
that's worth worth the [ __ ] price of
just getting the [ __ ] out of there okay
so you put them on either side of her
and then you have you know there's blood
pressure pumps ICU now she can't [ __ ]
move you know and then yeah then you got
an inflatable B bag right and then you
just guide her over you put it down on
the [ __ ] bean bag you open the door
and then you [ __ ] bring the blood
pressure pump just to the outside of the
door you close the door and right as
you're Barbie to close it you'll release
it you close the door and then your car
right you know that thing with your
[ __ ] running and if you feel
light-headed and [ __ ] and she's gonna be
come running down the hall after you now
it's like you're in a horror movie
you're trying to get your keys out and
if she [ __ ] comes you get in the
[ __ ] car hopefully you get the car
door closed before that [ __ ] lunatic
comes up to stick her [ __ ] arm in you
close the door you lock it then you know
what she's gonna do she's gonna stand
behind your [ __ ] car then all you do
is you just start the car up right on
you rev the [ __ ] engine get those
admissions in her face you listen to
some tunes eventually she's gonna have
to go to the bathroom and who knows
maybe an hour later maybe a [ __ ] hour
later you know you get the [ __ ] out of
there right 1995 I can put that in
infomercial not even infomercial that's
too much money I can do that in [ __ ]
30-second spot all right fellas
have you ever wanted to leave your
girlfriend's apartment but she won't let
you what do you do you've tried moving
her out of the way right right she yells
[ __ ] but the cops come in and [ __ ]
tackle you and showing you in a cell
with a [ __ ] giant cellmate looking at
you like he's gonna bang you in
right that's the first six seconds of
the commercial I think you guys can do
the rest of it maybe that's a reason to
have a four-wheel-drive vehicle so when
she's like standing behind you can't
back out you just put it Drive go right
up and over a curb I don't know I guess
what I'm really getting at here is I
hope you guys all enjoyed your holidays
your nice [ __ ] days off here you know
spend someone since I've had a day job
yet do you guys have to go back to work
today that's sucks man you know the day
after Christmas you're right back and
then let's see what is it
New Year's Day is what it's Sunday
yeah new use day Sunday but then they
play the bowl games on Monday so maybe
next weekend you get the [ __ ]
three-day weekend I have no [ __ ] idea
all I can say is [ __ ] you 2016 glad this
year's over me and you know a while ago
when they came up with the college
football playoff somebody playoff
somebody asked me to comment on it and I
was too [ __ ] busy headed in the
goddamn show I never really looked at it
and it just dawned on me that Ohio State
is in and Penn State is out how the [ __ ]
does that work somebody please explain
that to me
Penn State won the Big Ten championship
and they beat Ohio State Penn State's in
the [ __ ] Rose Bowl and Ohio State's
in the playoff and I got a friend of
mine as a Buckeyes fans and he's
bitching about Alabama dudes who
schedule all his [ __ ] he's wine it's
like how states should not [ __ ] be in
there that makes no [ __ ] sense
whatsoever and all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're gonna go well Alabama had a really
easy schedule SEC sucked this year
so what SEC was the whole [ __ ] year
was basically playing a national
championship game like [ __ ] two three
times
think the conference was that good for
10 years Alabama had to fight through
all of that so one time they get an easy
year
yeah anyways having said that I'm still
rooting against them cuz you have to
they're so [ __ ] good it's fun it's
fun and I told you my favorite thing in
sports
Alabama down at the half and then Nick
Saban has to talk to one of those
sideline reporter women you know other
ones do his [ __ ] slam some lockers
its chew out his punter or some [ __ ]
and he's got to sit there like I'm
telling you if anything is gonna put
that guy in an early grave it's that
[ __ ] interview he has to do so
anyways yeah I don't I mean I'm not like
anti Ohio State but that doesn't that
does not seem fair to me at all how does
a team that didn't win the big tension
didn't even win their [ __ ] conference
championship is in the Final Four it's
all [ __ ] it's all [ __ ] money it's
all money
Ohio State is gonna get better ratings I
bet it's gonna give them better ratings
than [ __ ] Penn State other than that
it makes no [ __ ] sense on paper you
know and I love those kids that are
gonna sit out their bowl game and
everybody's Lugar these sports talk
radio guys it's like dude it's [ __ ]
slave labor remember that dude on Ohio
State played that [ __ ] Penn State I
was at Willis from a gay he got his
[ __ ] knee blown out for free cost him
a career in the NFL if you didn't have
such a great [ __ ] agent yeah [ __ ] you
you're gonna sell sell it Jersey with
the kid's name on it you're gonna make
millions more the [ __ ] players are
selling out a hundred thousand seats
stadium and don't get a [ __ ] die
figure that one out all those players
throughout the [ __ ] century of the
damn team that have created the
excitement gone out there blown out
their knees got concussions got
paralyzed died early [ __ ] deaths do
not get one dime [ __ ] you and your
Bulgarians these kids money man it's
[ __ ] brutal it's brutal and I love
all the [ __ ] nerds that actually go
to class and they get mad at the
athletes because they don't show up it's
like hey [ __ ] if it wasn't for that
kid out there you would you would have a
class in a tent right now you know what
do you think paid for this this [ __ ]
biology class
huh people show 100,000 people showing
up to look at you look through a [ __ ]
microscope they didn't all right you
don't have a sexy job deal with it right
I don't get it
haven't said that I'm still gonna watch
and I don't know I like Clemson too but
uh I don't n guy - I probably still root
for how state but that that's so fun it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense I mean
there's always gonna be a reason to
complain because football such a violent
game that they can't have like March
Madness they just can't be too many
[ __ ] games and too many kids getting
hurt right
so every year someone's gonna get mad
and so I usually blow it off but this
year Penn State got [ __ ] you know I
mean maybe it's left over Sandusky [ __ ]
you know I mean like not enough time has
gone by it's gonna pause you to listen
all the Penn State fans go you know it's
funny is the [ __ ] Tom Brady
deflategate story lasted longer than
that send dusky [ __ ] and that's the
world that we live in all right let's
get to some of the questions here for
this week shall we oh how about the
[ __ ] Celtics man that Celtics Knicks
game was great the NBA - by the way
bravo for saying all right NFL you get
Thanksgiving we get Christmas they
actually muscled the NFL out of position
on a football Sunday to the point that
all the [ __ ] games are on Saturday
Saturday were there any NFL games
yesterday I didn't even look the NBA
games were so [ __ ] great I missed the
first one I watched the Celtics Knicks
great [ __ ] game then we almost blew
it here's the funny thing is Michael
Rapaport still owes me dinner from the
NBA Finals and that cuz he's a cheap
[ __ ] or anything is because
we're both [ __ ] busy and we just we
run into each other like once every six
months so Celtics are playing Knicks on
Christmas Day and I so I texted him I
said hey Mike you
go double enough him I'll take the
Celtics straight up and he goes
absolutely then he goes wait he goes so
if if I lose two I owe you two dinners I
go no you owe me breakfast
you only dinner and now you owe me
breakfast and then we'll bet on the
Super Bowl and if I win you know if you
if you win you don't owe me [ __ ] and if
I win you owe me breakfast lunch and
dinner you're gonna [ __ ] take me out
we're gonna do YouTube video have you
taken me out the entire [ __ ] day and
so he said all right so he's in so what
I'm hoping is that there's gonna be a
Patriots Giants [ __ ] the trilogy and
of course I'm taking my Patriots and I'm
hoping this is the year that our defense
doesn't let Tom Brady down because the
first two times we played the Giants he
drove them at the Patriots down the
field for the go-ahead score both times
he is 6 for 6 in Super Bowls when it is
counted right the time with Donovan
McNabb [ __ ] throws up Neal O'Donnell
throws a pick Peyton Manning throws a
pick 6 Tom Brady has manned up all six
he's gone 6 and OH
unfortunately his defense has gone
forward too so I want to see that
rematch and of course I'm gonna take the
Patriots and then I text them I said ok
so Patriots and Giants play each other
what's gonna happen the Patriots gonna
go oh and three no the Giants gonna guys
say the Giants gonna go three no against
the Patriots or is Michael Rapaport
gonna go oh and three against the menu
so hopefully that's gonna happen you
know I want the Patriots to play here we
go back to super we have to play the
[ __ ] charts I don't give a [ __ ] about
Seattle we already played them we
already beat him I don't give a [ __ ]
about anybody else we got it we got to
go back you got to do it you know I
talked to some [ __ ] Patriots fans I
go oh my god that makes me sick to my
stomach so what are you gonna quit I'm
gonna put you Paul Revere hat between
your [ __ ] legs and go home
you know I think the biggest thing this
year is they there's a coach even though
the coach is doing like a good job and
everything but you know I don't know I
just saw this is so stupid I just look
at a coach I judge a book by its cover
and I just look at that guy and I'm just
like yeah you know I'm not feeling it
I'm not feeling this guy this guy just
looks like it looks like a die-hard
Giants fan
that's what he looks like he does not
look like a head coach so anyways we
shall see and I told you I'm not buying
into I don't I don't buy I'm up I don't
believe in the Cowboys I don't like the
coach I look at him I'm like I do not I
just don't like that guy not like
personally don't like him I just look at
him and he just doesn't look at a head
coach like a head coach you got to look
at him you guys like oh man I would not
want to get yelled at by that guy I know
what you guys are thinking what about
Pete Carril Pete Carril looks like he's
going to Bible study yeah but if you
look into Pete Carroll has shark eyes
okay
I'm telling you that [ __ ] guy you
know I'm not trying to put rumors out
there but if that guy had like a dead
hooker in his past okay or at least you
know one that lost consciousness and he
brought her around you know it would not
surprise me that is so [ __ ] up to say
I'm sure he's a hell of a guy
all right let's get him let's uh let's
do some of the advertising here for the
he little ads here for the weaker right
all right see so everybody see so is the
place for comedy they won't tell you how
amazing they are but I will see so is
amazing it's comedy for comedy nerds by
comedy nerds see so spelled SE eso and
it is the new ad free streaming service
bringing you original series hand-picked
classic weeks of stand-up specials and
more benjamin comedy anytime anywhere on
seeso every episode of SNL including new
episodes the day they air The Tonight
Show Starring Jimmy Fallon and that the
Late Night with Seth Meyers
day after air and they even have
classics like 30 rock parks and recs
Saved by the Bell even British comedies
like the original office were freaky
Gervase he's drinking a beer the entire
Monty Python catalogue the it crowd and
Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge am I
supposed to know who the [ __ ] that is
Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge no way
that's his betters Harry Hamill is Steve
Rabinowitz critically acclaimed
originals and exclusive content like
Harmon quests created by comedian Dan
Harmon and funny as hell a variety show
featuring comedians such as Jim Jeffries
and Hannibal Buress if you're serious
about comedy if you got to try see so
streaming anytime anywhere alright let's
get to the point you see so is Ed free
and just 399 per month that's less than
you paid for the that latte or artisan
cold brewed coffee you're holding right
now right now my listeners can try see
so for free for two months when you use
the promo code burr at checkout shows
you can't get anywhere else from
critically acclaimed original series to
all 40 years of SNL
dude [ __ ] how much money is Lauren
Michaels making off of this he's got
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon
that's one of his boys Late Night with
Seth Meyers it's one of his boys 30 rock
that's one of his girls parks and recs
that's one of his girls saved by the
belt I don't know he's probably got
something with screech just go to see so
calm right now to sign up for two months
for free with the promo code burette
check out that see SOCOM promo code BRR
oh here we go but do do biondi's me
undies wearing them after Christmas but
who do me on DS be on DS you don't wanna
[ __ ] miss this does that rhyme you
[ __ ] balls will feel nice I got
nothing this week
I don't why did I pick Christmas let's
start take 2 take 2 write me undies me
undies soft as santa's beard but dude
dude do me on these me undies no one
will call you queered when you have is
beard up against your nuts C's Robin on
you Tate Sagna
ESU's you'll feel great during the
holidays skip it around returning the
gifts that you didn't like alright me
undies picture a world we're putting on
a pair of underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day think
about it underwear it's the first thing
you put on and the last thing you take
off unless you're Matthew McConaughey
why would you settle for anything less
than the best selling best feeling
underwear on the planet the undies
focuses solely on producing the most
comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced evidently it doesn't ride up
in your ass there my friends who have
never met how somehow we're friends at
me undies sent me a few pairs a while
back oh you think that's all you got to
do to become friends with me on that
superficial it really makes each day
better when you wear this underwear for
the price of two cocktails cocktails me
undies will deliver your new favorite
pair of underwear right to your doorstep
try them on if they're not the most
comfortable best feeling underwear
you've ever had that refund you let to
keep the first pair for free include in
the cluded in the price is the sweet
touch of modal a special phat Motel a
special fabric made of the best-in-class
raw materials are scientifically proven
to be three times softer than cotton
that's uber cozy undies are sold
exclusively on the manatees website
where you'll enjoy shipping for free in
the US and Canada all right and for a
limited time everyone everyone in my
audience gets 20% off their first order
but you have to go to our special URL me
undies com / / with the me undies better
day guarantee you have nothing to lose
so don't wait any longer go to me
Eddie's calm / but right now for 20% off
your first order that's me undies com /
/ oh jesus [ __ ] christ those ads is
so overwritten hold on one second all
right I'm back I'm back finally too
[ __ ] clear my goddamn throat ooh what
happens I woke up this morning but
doobly-do do and I just started doing
the podcast because I got to do a bunch
of [ __ ] today as always as always hey
Billy baldon Billy ball Dan you get it
Billy ball ding
this is Billy ball Danny's brother I
heard you ranting about how New England
keeps offloading defense defending
players you're half right but this year
is a big year for salary
cap don't what do you mean I'm half
right name one person that has finished
their [ __ ] career with the Patriots
on the defensive side since [ __ ] Tedy
Bruschi or [ __ ] Willie McGinest we
never keep him I'm not half right dude
Richard Seymour lawyer Milloy Ty Law uh
uh was a big [ __ ] numb oh my god I
can't believe it forgot his [ __ ] name
because they're only with us for a few
years who was the big fat guy our nose
tackle he's gone
I don't know anyways he said you're half
right
Dante Hightower and Malcom Butler both
in their mid-20s and in contracts years
expect both of them get big contracts in
the offseason I don't expect that I
don't expect that at all maybe one of
them will so what you're saying is I'm
half right you're saying expect them so
on your forecast I'm telling you what
has happened you're saying on your
forecast that you want you on you what
you are projecting
that that's that's one of your points
okay your first point is out the [ __ ]
window all right
that's science fiction there okay expect
to see both them get big contracts the
officer Patrick Chung the strong safety
is 30 now and we have a great young back
up in Landon Collins who is also in a
contract year okay so expect Patrick
Chung to get the [ __ ] heave-ho
because he's 30 and I would probably be
like hey I'm a veteran I play in this
league I've demonstrated I can do the
job and that's when they go okay [ __ ]
see you later
finally the Pro Bowl free safety Devin
McCourty is getting top dollar so it
isn't just the offense okay so in all of
that [ __ ] you just said you only named
one guy who's getting top dollar okay
everything else was projecting [ __ ]
right hope that brings some clarity to
Billy Super Bowls a pre trade deadline
move sending Jamie Collins another
middle linebacker entering a contract
year who was underperforming compared to
Hightower thanks for a great podcast
underperforming alright whatever I like
how you I like how you ignored
Chandler Jones who's having a [ __ ]
Pro Bowl year with Arizona you basically
told me that Devin McCourty is getting
paid
that's basically what you told me and
they've always paid guys who were in
their mid-20s what I'm talking about is
that next contract that next one they're
like yeah get the [ __ ] out of here you
out of here Patrick Chung get the [ __ ]
out of here all right here we go
I mean look as much as I'm complaining
it is working but it does get
frustrating to see these guys that you
shut down this side of the field in
every couple years we get rid of that
guy and like I always feel like you know
what I always feel like our defense you
know since the McGinnis Rabil and Tedy
Bruschi years I always feel like it goes
in it's like my pie it looks like it's
done but inside it's still soupy you
know so when we go up against the Giants
I just feel like we don't there was two
times we went up again we didn't match
up well against them they had a monster
defense you know and we're coming in
there you know we had Layana I just I
don't know I I love I that's why I love
two Giants I love the choice because
they always have a great [ __ ] defense
always have a great [ __ ] defense I
bet you know that's why I like the
Steelers back in the day the doomsday
defense the Cowboys you got to love
those teams you know because in your
offense can just be like good and you're
gonna win the [ __ ] game that's how
[ __ ] Mark Sanchez everybody lasts
they started calling Sanchez then [ __ ]
defense was great then they lost
everybody and all of a sudden you know a
USC boy there couldn't just manage the
game he had and then he had to play from
behind
he's a where do I go where do I go he
runs right into the [ __ ] ass of his
linemen and got a concussion well you
would have got a concussion no I
probably didn't got a concussion that
guy probably did too many squats his ass
is probably like an elbow all right
podcast inspired girlfriend to quit job
that was making her miserable Jesus
Christ this should be on The Oprah
Winfrey Network
we are we actually gonna have like a
feel-good [ __ ] story here [ __ ] is
going on with these blinds open the
blinds okay what are we get here 40
minutes in okay somebody gotta stretch
this [ __ ] into another 20 minutes
ignorant okay well bill you've been
doing great for the first 40 minutes
all right podcast inspired girlfriend a
quick job that was making her miserable
hey Billy Billy chick my girlfriend and
I love the podcasts and we listened to
it together whenever we're on a long
road trip a few months ago we put on
your interview with Joe Rogan when you
guys started talking about jobs you
hated and how you knew and how you had
to to know when to walk my girlfriend
started crying oh Jesus
up to that point I knew that she had
issues with the job but had no idea that
our company was putting her through so
much grief so much grief that was making
her absolutely miserable deep down
inside when she heard the interview it
convinced and inspired her to take
action as quickly as possible to seek
new employment good for her yeah and
that's a great habit to get into and you
do it when you [ __ ] young cuz you
don't have any kids no wife no husband
no mortgage that's when you [ __ ] make
your moves not to say you can't do it
after that but it's obviously you know
the there's there's no reason not to do
it when you're young okay now she's on
the right track for a really great job
and the possibilities of a permanent
hire with a really good company seem to
be in the works
seem to be in the works knock on wood I
would like to personally thank you mr.
Rogan for not only providing us with
great entertainment but also in
inadvertently helping out someone I
truly love and care about to seek a
positive work environment dude is there
gonna be anything I could make fun of in
this this is just like a nice letter she
is also she is already in better spirits
than ever before is in part thanks to
you hope to see you come through the
Carolinas next time around thanks again
and have a wonderful holiday well that's
great all I can do is reiterate I can't
remember what the [ __ ] I said but yeah
you know I I had a friend of mine that
was working for was working for the
sleek company I think it was Nestle as
one of those [ __ ] corporations and
they will run in this person ragged and
I literally watched this person go from
a positive person to somebody that I
started to avoid his phone calls because
like it was getting so [ __ ] negative
and then one day this person just said
[ __ ] this quit and actually started
working for like a non-profit and was
Happy's [ __ ] hell and is now back in
the corporate world at a company that he
[ __ ] loves and like you have to
[ __ ] do that man you know that whole
[ __ ] fear of like you know how am I
gonna pay for [ __ ] we'll keep you in
these bad relationships with these
horrific [ __ ] companies right but
what you have you have to always be
willing to sacrifice for your own
happiness and if that involves
downsizing your [ __ ] life and just
getting just looking at all the [ __ ] on
your shelves and all of this stuff that
you [ __ ] have and be like how much of
this [ __ ] do I even [ __ ] need because
I'm sitting here you know in our guest
room where I have all my drum videos my
magazines all these [ __ ] books
they've just sat on the shelf for
[ __ ] years like if you literally took
everything off of this [ __ ] shelves
okay other than the sentimental value of
a few [ __ ] things I wouldn't you can
empty all the [ __ ] this little
cabinets if you emptied all of it
other than and when I walked in and I
didn't see it I wouldn't miss any of it
except for I have the 1970 is it 1972
it's the most expensive years of
football cards I have the complete set
that I would miss that I would miss
there's a couple other things I got up
there but other than that I said you
know I'm you know what I'm gonna get rid
of all that [ __ ] [ __ ] right downsize
my [ __ ] but I'm saying you can do that
think about when you first [ __ ] you
know moved out of your house what did
you have you had to close on your back a
couple piece of [ __ ] things of furniture
right and then
not just over the years you get
subscriptions to magazines you say they
just start collecting [ __ ] people give
you stuff you go on [ __ ] trips and
you buy shot glasses and then all of a
sudden what you really yep your house is
just this giant storage shed for a bunch
of [ __ ] that you don't leave your
apartment becomes the same way so if you
downsize all of that to get out of a
[ __ ] job you don't want to be in and
you reduce your [ __ ] overhead in the
meantime you can actually make less you
know there's all different ways to get
out of the job start spending less
saving up [ __ ] money so you can quit
your job and live for four months
without having to [ __ ] work or
whatever or making a little bit less
money in the meantime just get rid of a
bunch of [ __ ] that you don't even
[ __ ] need I got to do that but the
baby coming any [ __ ] day now I got a
I got to get rid of a bunch of [ __ ] cuz
God knows she's gonna have a bunch of
[ __ ] too right
I don't [ __ ] know anyways here we go
let's [ __ ] let's let's plow ahead
here uh return gifts alright dear bill I
got to get into a debate with my fiancee
I got into a debate with my fiancee she
seems to think it's rude
I don't be rude it seems to be rude to
ask someone for a gift receipt for a
gift they did not like I told her that
it would be worse to keep the gift and
never use it than to return for a better
size of something different altogether I
take you for the type of guy to just say
thank you and and throw it out if you
don't like it good call man I have I
don't like something I would never die I
just don't do that I just I take it down
to Goodwill
I got a jacket for my aunt that I don't
like and doesn't fit she thinks I should
just exchange it for a proper size and
call it a day I know for a fact that my
aunt wouldn't be offended because we're
close enough that I can tell her that
thoughts on this you know this is one
that I think is up to you I think it's a
good exercise to tell somebody what
you're really feeling
at the price of their feelings I don't
know if it's with the Christmas gift I
think you can do it once to somebody but
if next year if they come back with
something ugly again then you're just
saying you know you have bad tastes but
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it
I think there's anything wrong with it
and if they look I gotta be honest you
go up I got somebody a [ __ ] gift
right now if they didn't start screaming
at me make me sit down like if I ever
got if I ever got my wife a gift she's
like you know I don't like this could I
exchange it again [ __ ] yeah absolutely
here's a receipt have fun going to those
crowded malls I'm done I I have
fulfilled my end of the verbal
contractual agreement that we have that
I will buy you a Christmas gift but you
know when you go to return the [ __ ]
thing I mean that's on you you can go
back in there with all those [ __ ]
animals again I'm not doing it yeah I
don't think there's anything wrong with
it I think that that's maybe that's a
preference thing you know if you want to
[ __ ] if you want to go that route you
know god bless you you go that [ __ ]
route if you don't I respect that too
all right I slapped my sister on
Christmas Eve I don't believe this I
don't believe this at all dear Billy
[ __ ] tits
I'm [ __ ] tits and you slapped a woman
hey Billy recently my family celebrated
my dad's birthday which is on Christmas
Eve and like every year we went to a
local Mexican restaurant my mother
bought him a very expensive bottle of
Middleton triple distilled Irish whiskey
I've never heard of that [ __ ] I hope I
said it right which we proceeded to
drink once we returned to my parents
house all right how many of you are on
this bottle and there's a woman slapped
in the end of this Jesus Christ this is
like a [ __ ] country music video once
we were back my sister who's 30 asked if
she could collect pictures of us as
little kids she could make an album I
see I knew exactly where some great ones
were of her as a baby and my mother's
drawer where she my mother had
previously shown me
you know I don't know what's gonna
happen in this thing or if it's even a
true story but I'm already saying at
some point somebody should have said
fair enough before somebody gets slapped
or he goes my sister has a different
father than I and from what I gather her
dad was a not-so-great guy and my mother
doesn't seem to have any fun memories of
that relationship okay
I presented the pictures to her
expecting her to have either seen them
before or to be thrilled to be seeing
them for the first time the pictures
were of her and her father with my
mother's family I'm getting lost here
okay okay okay you guys have the same
mom but different dads okay also her
birth certificate was in the certificate
was in the envelope which she apparently
which apparently she had never seen
she's 30 she's never had to produce a
birth certificate once she saw them she
freaked out she began to berate my
mother for never showing them to her in
a full-blown fight ensued of course I
was mortified I had no idea this was
going to happen I'm gonna go out on a
limb here so I say at this moment this
is not about you anymore okay I mean she
didn't have a good relationship with her
dad this could be you know something
that she needed or something this seems
to be between her and her mom and if
you're gonna go third man in that's a
game as conduct and I would say a
[ __ ] 10 game suspension at least she
sets horribly hurtful things to my
mother and tried to storm out once I
stepped in and tried to stop her oh now
you're doing that thing so women need
this product to [ __ ] they'd make a
zillion dollar the male or female person
remover how ignorant am I then I never
thought that a woman ever had to [ __ ]
try to get through the door with some
[ __ ] [ __ ] guys doing my apology to
all the ladies all right once I stepped
in and tried once I stepped in and tried
to stop her she began to attack me and
shout out everything that was wrong with
me in my life I defended myself yelling
back all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] she's done
that's not defending yourself sir what
you did was you went to her emotional
level which she should have done was
just laid on the [ __ ] ropes let her
go and then afterwards she would hold
you an apology
anyways he goes then with my this is
this is why you don't go home for the
holidays
this [ __ ] always ends up happening then
with my mother and father there she
charged me and punched me square in the
eye with this insane look on her face
well she wanted to leave and you weren't
letting her I was trying to keep her at
arm's length and telling myself over and
over don't hit her the final straw came
when with both my parents trying to hold
her back she managed to kick me in the
face with her boots on aren't you
standing up how the [ __ ] did she do that
they held her back in tech gave her
leverage or stirred she liked Anderson
silver and she just gave me that front
up kick that you didn't say whatever the
[ __ ] you call it in MMA terms then I
proceeded calmly and coolly to pick the
exact moment when to reach in and give
her an open palm slap right across the
whole left side of her face you did that
calmly and coolly Jesus she immediately
stopped a tirade and went in her car to
pout well have to he slapped her in the
face I don't she's pouting
she later chilled out and fell asleep on
the sofa Christmas being tomorrow I need
your help
did I do the wrong thing and how can I
keep things from being [ __ ] up from
here on out thank you and go [ __ ]
yourself did you do the wrong thing you
slapped a woman yes
I mean she's coming at you with a knife
then yeah you can go close fist it at
that point but I mean all she was trying
to do was leave um here's the thing dude
she had a valid reaction to something
that really hurt her and in her pain she
said a bunch of mean things to her mom
all right
now she comes from a broken home I mean
this shit's gonna happen during the
[ __ ] holidays you're [ __ ] drunk on
whiskey right you guys have feuds
what I can tell there's only two of you
on that bottle maybe three or whatever
but you know three four people killing a
bottle of whiskey you're all
to be hammer alright then she wanted to
leave now if she's drunk and she wants
to drive that's one thing he did not put
that in there if she just wanted to
leave to go be by herself there's
nothing more frustrating than when
you're hurt and you're emotional you
want to leave a room and people won't
let you leave it's [ __ ] annoying
alright if she has no history of trying
to hurt herself she's not drunk you got
to let her leave the fact that you just
said you calmly coolly waited for the
[ __ ] exact moment to reach in and
slap her across the face means you
contemplated this shit's like she hit
you and then you reacted and did it you
made the decision he thought about it
and you waited for them so that went
from like [ __ ] second-degree to
first-degree so ya know you didn't do
the right thing and you should I would
feel terrible if I [ __ ] did that and
how can you stop things from being
[ __ ] up from here on out well I would
sit down and I would just keep playing
over and over again how it escalated and
you kind of zigged every time you should
have zagged and just try to think of
what you can do the next time but calmly
coolly picking the exact moment to slap
your sister in the face on Christmas Eve
isn't yeah I would say you did the wrong
thing I mean like I said literally
unless she was literally gonna be doing
physical harm to I guess she hit you
that god that's so [ __ ] up I'm not
even thinking that she kicked you in the
face and she did all of that type of
stuff I still gotta say cuz they were
holding her back
it's just one of the things that women
get to get away with they get it they
get to get away with this all better and
usually like you shouldn't [ __ ] hit
him but how [ __ ] up is it that even as
a guy I wasn't even validating the point
that she kicked you in the face and
punched you square in the eye with an
insane look on her face I think it's
very easily for me to be sitting here in
bed not emotionally invested in a this
to say whether the [ __ ] you did the
right thing and the wrong thing
you know you got a your family's going
through a [ __ ] up time you through
alcohol in there and some old [ __ ]
pictures and you know your sister you
know puts their hands on you and you hit
her back I mean I don't know I don't
know I would have to look maybe cuz you
said you calmly and coolly pick the
exact moment when to reach out I don't
know maybe that's what [ __ ] threw me
off but like if this all went down in
like [ __ ] three seconds you know I
think you guys all need some [ __ ]
group therapy all I can say is I'm glad
I wasn't there I'm glad I wasn't at that
party that's all I can say about that
one however I do feel that I owe you an
apology
but judging your actions without even
taking into consideration that you took
two hits to the head to the face you hit
me in the face right and you know I've
seen women like that and I know how hard
they punch and kick and all that [ __ ]
they have no [ __ ] concern for the
fact that they're wearing shoes and they
kick you in the face so just said you
know if they weigh over a hundred pounds
and who wants to get hit by somebody
weighs 100 pounds right in the [ __ ]
face
you don't and that the natural reaction
to getting hit is to hit back and they
got that whole well because I'm a girl
you can't do it yet I can just [ __ ]
break all the [ __ ] rules in the you
know it's it's it's one of the things
but you know something I maybe that's
just one of the one of the perks you get
for being a woman you know they gotta
have their period every month they got
to go through [ __ ] labor you know
what I mean
they gotta get all those free drinks
they always get the house during a
divorce I mean there's a lot of things
that they have to go through that maybe
maybe it's okay that they can hit us I
have no [ __ ] idea all I know is that
you know if a woman ever hits you you
just you just [ __ ] walk away you just
walk away and if they're not related to
you you just end the relationship like
this is over yeah you know are you
coming back to you didn't get me a gift
now where I'm like the battered woman
now I'm like oh wait she's usually not
like that she shuts a good for us to go
[ __ ] yourself over
all right so what I do if I okay did I
do the wrong thing and how can I keep
things from being [ __ ] up from here on
out okay this is what the first thing
you do I would not drink whiskey around
volatile family members I wouldn't do
that I would try to be the sober person
I think if you were more sober and I you
probably wouldn't have done that or the
very least you would have saw the punch
coming sounded like she threw a straight
right you know she should have maybe a
little slip that you know I'm [ __ ]
with sorry that that happened and you
know I don't know you guys kind of
evened out she hit you twice you only
hit her once said maybe that's fair who
the [ __ ] knows I don't [ __ ] know but
I I don't I don't buy into that whole
chivalry thing that you know the yeah
once somebody starts swinging on you
it's they if they've they've [ __ ] you
know they've waived all rights of
chivalry and in rules between the sexes
in my own opinion but like it's the fet
it's but for the guy though is if he
reacts immediately I give you a pass but
the fact that you thought about it it
shows to come back to even though she
deserves it she's still a lady and then
you don't I mean personally I could I
could well I guess she never say never
but I've never run into that and I've
had a lot of women hit me I mean I'm an
[ __ ] I've had a lot of women hit me
I've had women throw [ __ ] at me but it's
never it's never gotten to that point
where I I I would I couldn't do that
she's a bill it's like hitting a [ __ ]
kid or a dog or some [ __ ] you know I
couldn't I couldn't do it like an animal
they're defenseless you know to me
unless it's like Ronda Rousey who's
fighting this [ __ ] weekend everybody
you know the [ __ ] if you if you're
there's a question for you if you're
dating someone who is not just takes
karate or [ __ ] MMA [ __ ] is actually
in the UFC then what does that become
you know what I mean if she [ __ ] hits
you say you survive that
Oh God
there's not a woman who's even remotely
thought about getting into the UFC that
couldn't kick the [ __ ] out of me I can't
imagine fighting one that was actually
in the UFC every [ __ ] hilarious
then later they're apologizing as I have
a stake over my eye I'll make it up to
you freckles all right ex-girlfriend is
a [ __ ]
Jesus [ __ ] James Blunt here
ex-girlfriend is a [ __ ] hey Bill I am a
lady and a huge fan of yours I love Nia
as well get her on the case if possible
please
well she's still downstairs sleeping
okay I dig other ladies and recently I
broke up I broke a very important
relationship in my life I was dating
this girl on and off for many years and
felt totally in love with her all the
while she claims she loved me more than
anything which she still does claim by
the way by the way and says I'm the only
person she has ever wanted to spend her
life with
however she's one of these people who
just needs her freedom and can't
function in a [ __ ] relationship well
then you got to let her go
before we broke up we had this huge
[ __ ] argument about commitment and I
said I didn't see the point in
continuing this relationship she
reflected on it and said I was
absolutely right that I don't deserve to
dedicate my entire life to someone as
complicated as her well yeah
agree with her and walk I agreed she
then said she tried but can't
reciprocate my feelings in the same
intensity all right that was eight years
before this broad was jerking me around
saying I'm the love of her life and she
wanted to marry me and live with me
forever
all these years every time I confronted
her about her troublesome behavior there
was never cheating at least she didn't
tell me hey I don't think our feelings
match this may not work she led me to
believe she loved me enough she's still
saying I'm the love of her life and
whatnot but feels horrible for all the
pain she's caused me and the
I wasted I said being in love the love
of her life wasn't enough to make her
act like a good girlfriend and then I
wanted to move on with my life so we
parted ways good for you
strong move I like that move now I'm not
sure what to do where to start my
identity is so intertwined with this
intertwine with this person you know we
used to be in the beginning I want to
start over but I don't know who I am
outside of this relationship I'd like to
hear your thoughts about it because I
think you guys give some good advice all
right I would say this what you're
feeling is totally normal and what a lot
of people do is when they feel those
feelings of like well now what do i do
who am i how do I pick up the [ __ ]
pieces there is that initial feeling
which does not feel good and your
natural reaction is to go for the
quickest fix which is to go back into
that [ __ ] horrible relationship what
you have to do as the song goes you got
to walk through the fire here I would
write down you know I've started journal
or something so you can kind of you know
it's something to just be feeling your
thoughts versus writing them down and
then you can see them and then you can
kind of get outside of yourself which is
what you need right now and you know
friends help with this too we have to be
like look you can't go back to this
person you know that okay but right now
is like the worst part is now you're
gonna be lonely and heartbroken by
yourself and this person that usually
comfort you is the cause of it so you
can't go to them for comfort because
it's gonna [ __ ] you all up and get you
back to square one so you're asking what
you should do is I think that you should
acknowledge the fact that you're gonna
you have to go through some pain you're
gonna go through some pain over the next
like you know certainly three months but
what you do during that time is you
gradually build a new life without this
person so the first month you're gonna
be in the fetal position crying and just
you know going through the next show
that's like going through detox of this
person but
I would try to do is introduce a new fun
activity you know that you could do like
I don't know whatever the [ __ ] it's into
even if it's like a [ __ ] TV show that
he meant to binge watch something as
simple as that that is something that
you do and in that it's yours that you
don't do with this other person and then
you just introduce something else that
when you're ready for something else
maybe you always wanted to learn how to
ride a horse go [ __ ] do that God
knows you got the goddamn time something
fun but there's something that you've
always wanted to do but you didn't have
the time with work and being involved in
a relationship go do that [ __ ] thing
take a trip do something and all the
time when you're feeling sad give in to
the sadness and cry some of that [ __ ]
pain out I'm a big believer in crying
it's something that guys are not allowed
to do it's why women get passionate and
guys carry [ __ ] women still can look
back and see the sadness but that done
feeling [ __ ] up over because they
didn't hold on to the emotion they let
the emotion out guys hold the [ __ ]
thing and like I believe that guys
should you know because it's too
embarrassing for people to see his cry
they should in every house the way you
have a bathroom a bedroom a kitchen
there should be a crying room for the
man he goes into closes the door it's
soundproof and he's allowed to go in
there and wail out all of his [ __ ]
pain the way women are and everyone
flocks to him and hugs him and gives him
comfort and you know I'm a big believer
in it now then after after half a
century Holden and then I believe that
you should [ __ ] let it out you should
go Chris Bosh if you're a guy so that's
what I would say to you and just
acknowledge the fact that this is gonna
hurt I'm proud of that you got out of
this relationship you know eight years
of this person jerking you around and
you know what you did you got out of
something toxic and you opened the door
for the right person to come into your
life you know something that's gonna
respect you make you laugh and you have
a great time you know and one day you're
gonna look back on what the [ __ ] that I
waste eight years with that person you
know why you did so you could realize
how great the person that's gonna come
into your life is gonna be and there you
go there's your pep talk all right you
can do it I believe in you all right
here we go let's read the last two
[ __ ] ads here
then I gotta get the full catty right Oh
blue apron everybody hey is something
you could do by the way the person just
I just read because one of the things
you might want you you might do is eat a
bunch of food and put on [ __ ] weight
you don't want to do that you know
that's like another be another bad
[ __ ] thing that this person created
they broke your heart now they're gonna
[ __ ] put more stress on your heart
because you're gonna be bad food you
know I'd be great the thing is he ate
healthy meals and you know what you're
crying you're in the fetal position
would it be great if somebody just
brought the food to you blue apron this
is like the [ __ ] that this is the
best move you can make if you go through
a breakup right here blue apron they're
gonna bring you a healthy food it's easy
to [ __ ] cook you're gonna stay in
shape right as you get over that [ __ ]
last [ __ ] a [ __ ] that was in your
[ __ ] life and you be a good shape
thus baby attracting somebody else in
your life who knows but do not just jump
into something I forgot that part of the
advice do not jump into another [ __ ]
relationship I would stay after an
eight-year thing you need to stay single
for at least a [ __ ] year I would
think and that'll make you so [ __ ]
strong you you you you'll be looking
back on I can't believe I used to be
that other person okay blue apron not
all ingredients are created equal fresh
high-quality ingredients make a real
difference so it's important to know
where your food comes from it's
affordable for less than ten dollars per
meal
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre-portion and greens to
make delicious home-cooked meals choose
from a variety of new recipes each week
I'll let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you recipes are not repeated
within a year so you never gonna get
bored and it's flexible customize your
rest your recipes each week based on
your preferences blue apron has several
delivery options so you choose what fits
your needs and there's no weekly
commitment so you only get deliveries
when you want them each meal comes with
step-by-step easy to follow a recipe
card and pre-portioned agrees and can be
prepared in 40 minutes or less blue
aprons freshness guarantees promise
promises that every ingredient in your
delivery arrives ready to cook alright
here we go
this is how you get check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals for free with free shipping by
going to blue apron com / / that's blue
apron com / / blue ape
a better way to cook and lastly but not
leastly stamps.com you don't have time
to go to the post office post office so
what do you do I use stamps comm instead
with stamps uh calm you can avoid all
the hassle man of going to the post
office during the busy holiday season
then the mailman picks it up I use
stamps comb to send on all my posters
when I'm on the road trust me if I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure it out so can you
it's that easy right now I can get you a
better offer from stamps comm and what's
on the homepage sign up for the for
stamps calm and use my last name burr to
get a four week trial plus $110 bonus
offer including postage and a digital
scale go to Stan's comm click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in / that's stamps.com
enter ber alright that's the podcast for
this week enjoy
between the christmas hanukkah kwanzaa
in the new year's that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
Thursday